So who's my guest this week?
It is the Democratic Senator,
Foreign Affairs Expert
and former vice presidential
candidate, Tim Kaine.
I'm sending a clear message to the world.
America is back.
But as we've seen with
the conflict in Ukraine,
diplomacy is far more
complicated than soundbites.
President Biden's performance
regarding Russia and Ukraine
hasn't been graded yet,
but for all the re-engagement
there have been missteps too.
When that judgment is made,
my guest will play a part.
Sitting on the Senate
Committee on Foreign Relations,
he's a Washington pro who's
been within spitting distance
of the vice presidency twice.
Now he's focused on as he puts it,
"Protecting the Constitution
from the enemies of democracy,
foreign and domestic."
And after suffering from long COVID,
"Ensuring those still
affected by the pandemic
are not forgotten."
With Russia accused of
war crimes in Ukraine.
How does he think America and the world
should deal with Vladimir Putin?
And on a more personal note,
how do you get over nearly
being vice president of America
twice?
When John Kerry became Secretary of State,
he had a knock at the door that
morning and it's John McCain
He said, "I gotta tell you,
you and I are the only
people in the Senate
who have gone through what
you've just gone through.
We are the only two now that
have been on a national ticket
and lost, and I'll tell you,
I've got the solution for you."
And I said, "I'm all ears."
He said, "Just go right back to work."
I said, "You found me here.
First thing, first day we're open,
you found me here didn't you?"
There's been multiple
reports of war crimes,
now, including the raping
of Ukrainian women.
Russian authorities have denied all.
If the evidence is there,
do you think we'll ever see
Putin in The Hague on charges?
When you target civilians
that's a war crime
and I believe he needs to get
the Slobodan Milošević treatment
and the US needs to press for that.
Thank you so much for joining me.
Very good to have your company today,
Senator Kaine.
Indeed Emma.
I wanted to start talking about
how some have described it
as confusing, foreign policy
under President Biden.
In one sense, we get told
at the beginning of his
administration, "America's back"
and we see quite quickly
in terms of diplomacy.
A first major overseas act was
to withdraw from Afghanistan.
And now we see engagement with Ukraine.
How would you define
how it is at the moment?
Emma I think the real key to
the Biden Administration, "America's back"
is America's back to
link arms with allies.
That's the hallmark of this administration
that is the dramatic departure
from the Trump Administration.
President Trump was a unilateral guy.
He didn't like alliances,
he didn't like treaties.
He didn't like multiparty trade deals,
it was all one-on-one.
And that left many of
America's traditional allies
wondering,
you know, is this just President Trump
or is the United States,
even the citizenry
kind of retreating from
linking arms with allies?
Well, President Biden with a
long track record of chairing
the Foreign Relations
Committee in the Senate,
his work as Vice President
with leaders around the world
is back in a big way,
whether it's getting back in
the Paris Climate Accords,
restarting negotiations with
Iran to see whether we can work
in a multination deal to
stop a nuclear program there.
But most recently the work
in Ukraine to assemble NATO
and non-NATO nations in a
very, very strong alliance
to put multiple pressure points on Russia
because of their illegal
invasion of Ukraine.
I see this as an administration,
that's really committed
to America's role in the world,
but particularly in linking arms with,
with allies and growing
that number of allies.
I suppose it's just, I'm very minded.
One of my guests, the Women's
Minister of Afghanistan.
Yes.
And she's now living out of a suitcase
as a refugee in London,
thinking, "If America's back,
how am I in this situation?"
And she described the most terrible escape
from Afghanistan under the Taliban.
And that doesn't feel
like America is back.
She's worried, she's
concerned that America
has forgotten Afghanistan.
Well, we haven't forgotten.
There are 76,000 Afghans
who are living in the United States,
who weren't living here in August.
And Virginia, actually,
the State that I represent
is one of the most common places.
Folks came to Virginia initially,
the resettlement processing
was largely done in Virginia.
And the permanent
residences of many of these
are in Virginia.
Now there's many more who wanna come
and we're gonna work on them,
but we have not forgotten that at all.
But what President Biden concluded
and I agreed with this conclusion is,
we had done as much with
the military as we could do.
And the next chapter in
Afghan life had to be
primarily directed by Afghans
and the continuing military presence
of the US after 20 years,
should it be for 30 years?
should it be for 50 years?
And so he made that painful decision.
And part of the decision,
I think the only way to
understand it is also,
we now view sort of the,
Russia and China as the great threats,
the great adversaries.
For a long time, we defined
our adversary primarily
as non-state terrorism,
but now we're seeing a different threat
from China and Russia in particular.
And that means we have to
redeploy resources against the
most significant challenges that we face.
And that's another reason why
20 years of military
investment in Afghanistan
should come to an end.
If that makes sense on paper,
but the reality was very messy.
It wasn't a good withdrawal.
And now the country's
on the brink of famine.
And Yemen is, and Sudan
is, and Ethiopia is
and Ukraine as a bread basket of the world
that will create famine
issues around the country.
And we have an obligation
through our humanitarian budget
and in other diplomatic ways to try to
provide support for
Afghans and we're going to.
But the military engagement
needed to come to an end.
Of course now looking back
and looking towards Ukraine
and what's happened there,
President Zelenskyy has given
an interview to the Economist
in which he talked
about Western countries,
which either want a long
war to exhaust Russia,
or those who are more
concerned about humanitarian
and economic side effects
who wants a short war.
Which camp does America fit into?
We want a short war.
The Biden Administration has decided that
there should not be, at this moment,
there should not be US
Troops in or over Ukraine.
But the scale of military
support that we're providing
Ukrainians is massive.
$3 billion of US Military
aid went to Ukraine
from 2014 through the end of '21
a billion of that in 2021.
We've just voted to send about
$6.7 billion of military aid
to Ukraine and an equal
amount of humanitarian aid
and other nations are doing the same.
But I will credit President Zelenskyy,
we are not seeing the result
as quickly as any of us
would like.
The economic pressure campaign,
canceling Nord Stream 2,
UN resolutions, the intense sanctions,
banning Russian oil imports.
These are all having a very
significant effect on Russia,
just as our military aid
is helping Ukrainians
extract great cost from Russia,
but we're not seeing a
positive outcome as quickly
as any of us would like.
So do you think America's done enough?
I think we can do more
and we are doing more.
I think this very bipartisan vote
to do the $13.5 billion of
military and humanitarian aid
combined with
the work that President
Biden and the team has done
to encourage other countries to do a lot,
it's pretty significant.
As you know, Emma, when you see
non-NATO nations like Sweden and Finland,
putting military aid into
the Ukrainian defense force
and considering joining NATO,
which would've been an
anathema five years ago
in those countries.
When you look at Germany
sending military aid to Ukraine,
they've had a tradition of
not putting military aid
into conflict zones since
the end of World War II.
When you look at Switzerland
being willing to play
a really important role in the sanctions
nations are getting off
the sidelines and realizing
this is a fight between
democracy and tyranny
and democracy has to win.
There's been multiple
reports of war crimes.
Now, including the raping
of Ukrainian women,
Russian authorities have denied all.
If the evidence is there
do you think we'll ever see
Putin in The Hague on charges?
We need to.
I started a call for this
really at the end of the
first week of the war
at the end of February,
because it appeared to me that
there was this indiscriminate
targeting of civilians, which is,
you know, the war is
illegal in and of itself,
the invasion of sovereignty,
but when you target civilians,
that's a war crime.
And I believe he needs to get
the Slobodan Milošević treatment
and the US needs to press for that.
Will we see him in The Hague?
We need to do everything we
can to make sure that he is.
How could you do that?
You would have to find some
agreement within the UN
to press forward on that
as was done in the case of the Balkans.
Now Russia, as a Security Council Member
has the ability within
the Security Council
to exercise a veto.
But they don't have a veto on everything
within the General Assembly.
So we would need to look
at the broader UN to see
whether we could promote
a similar tribunal
as was the case in the Balkans.
Now, none of this will shame Putin.
I don't believe he can be shamed,
but it might shame Russians
to be a pariah nation
led by a leader who's a war criminal.
So you see him as utterly shameless?
Personally, yes, but again, the,
not everyone in Russia,
not all the leadership
and certainly not the
citizenry are without shame.
Russian people are strong
people and good people.
And I think if they had
access to information,
which they don't.
I think they would be ashamed
that their nation is being led by somebody
who is committing war crimes.
How do you explain the invasion?
How can you try and understand
what it's all about?
Because we're now looking at, as you say,
a much longer fight
than perhaps either side
could ever have had imagined.
I mean, it's an interesting question.
Let me take you back a little bit.
The US and European allies,
we're seeing the same data
and President Zelenskyy too.
Amassing of troops on the
border, exercises in Belarus.
But we were interpreting
the data differently.
And during my time in the Senate,
there hasn't been as wide a divergence.
The US was interpreting the data as
there's gonna be an invasion.
Most of the European nations
and President Zelenskyy,
they were at least saying,
we don't think that's going to happen.
And there might have been a little bit of
diplomacy in those words,
but there was some sharp
difference of opinion
about whether this was just
a border exercise to flex,
or whether there was gonna be an invasion.
The US Intelligence was right about this.
How do I explain it?
I believe, although the
countries are very different
and the individuals are very different.
Vladimir Putin and Xi Jinping
are similar in that they
each have an ideal for their
country that I would call,
they kind of view themselves
as historical rejuvenators.
They're trying to
rejuvenate something that
they felt was lost in the past.
And that explains China
aspirations with respect to Taiwan.
And it explains Putin's aspirations
with respect to Ukraine.
Particularly because in his view,
Modern Russia started with the
Christianization of Russia,
which began in Ukraine.
And so in his mind, there's
sort of this mythology
about what the greater Russia is
and Ukraine is very central to that.
Can I ask you something about your leader,
President Biden?
In March on a visit to Poland,
an important visit where
he said nine words,
"For God's sake this man
cannot remain in power."
Talking about Putin.
As someone who is very familiar
with how diplomacy works,
how it should work.
Where were you when you
heard what he had said?
And what was your reaction?
Well, I wouldn't have said it.
I wouldn't have said it because the US,
neither the United States,
nor the Biden Administration,
considers regime changes as
an element of foreign policy.
Now in the past, the US did
that and often got it wrong.
We failed so often when
we attempted to presume
who another country's leader should be.
President Biden said pretty plainly look,
"Regime change isn't the US policy,
but I was just speaking outta my sense of
moral outrage at the
activities of Vladimir Putin."
And I credit him for that.
One of the things about Joe
Biden that I really like,
is he's a man who speaks from the heart
and it's not gonna
always be poll tested or
everything that has to be
written by five speech writers.
And so he was expressing an outrage that
frankly, the entire world feels,
and those words did bring
some comfort to Ukrainians
and Russian opposition.
But the US doesn't have a
policy of regime change.
But it was clumsy from
your ultimate diplomat,
more than clumsy.
In fact, I mean,
I think it's important to hear
what you think about the idea
that this is the greatest gift
for the Russian propaganda machine.
Well, I don't, again, I
wouldn't have said it,
but I will say, one of Biden's strengths
is he plays from the heart.
It's not all poll tested and it's not all
eight speech writers control what he says.
He plays from the heart and that--
So did Donald Trump.
That statement did express
a very sincere revulsion
at what Putin is doing
the world should be revulsed.
If I put it
I recognize you wouldn't say it,
sorry to cut across you Senator but--
Yeah.
You know, if Donald Trump had said that
people on your side of politics
would be jumping all over that saying,
"He doesn't know how to do diplomacy,
these are the sorts of gaffes
that we shouldn't be hearing,
this isn't the way that we do politics."
Because his whole,
President Biden's whole play
was diplomacy is back.
The grown ups are back.
But I disagree with you.
I don't think there's any
equivalence between the two.
And frankly, what we had
with Donald Trump was
cozying up to Vladimir Putin.
I mean, at least Joe
Biden sees Vladimir Putin
for who he is.
I mean, let's be honest here.
The guy has invaded a country illegally
and he's committing war crimes.
Joe Biden sees that for what it is,
Donald Trump admired that
about Vladimir Putin.
So there's no real
equivalence between 'em.
Well, President Trump's not
in this particular scenario
at this time, of course, much criticism
has been leveled at him about
exactly as you described,
but I'm more trying to say,
here you've got the President
of the United States,
billing himself as the
experienced diplomat.
And there he goes and says something,
which really is a gift for Putin.
All right, so put that
on one side of the ledger
and then on the other
side of the ledger put,
persuaded the Germans to cancel
the Nord Stream 2 pipeline,
assembled an international
sanctions regime
that's been joined by dozens
and dozens of countries.
Reinvigorated NATO's commitment
to defensive democracies,
got non-NATO nations to also
agree to send military aid
into Ukraine.
I agree you can put those comments
on the negative side of the ledger,
but I think the positive
side of the ledger
is much longer with respect
to what's going on right now
in Ukraine.
A as you would see it, and
those are important points.
And of course, many people
also talking about, you know,
nobody wanted this war,
nobody wanted this invasion,
but there has been greater
unity of NATO because of it.
And that strengthening of the alliance.
I suppose it just also
allows me to put to you
some of the concerns some have had
not just in America, but around the world
that perhaps Joe Biden,
this maybe adds to the perception
that when he does ad-lib
and he gets it wrong
from the perspective of
not recommending regime change,
that perhaps he isn't as fit
or quite as up to the job
as some have been concerned about.
Polls in America have shown
concerns about the fact he's nearly 80.
And in November, for instance, his team
put out a statement saying
he had developed a stiffer,
less fluid gait as a result
of his advancing age.
He's 80 years old,
but I can tell you from
personal experience,
I was with the president two Fridays ago
when he invited me to the Oval Office
with the family of a New York
physician who died by suicide
in the early days of
COVID in April of 2020.
And we got a bill passed in her honor
to try to make sure that
our healthcare providers
get mental health
resources that they need.
You know, I saw that in
the Oval Office, when he,
you know, pulled aside
Lauren's mother and sister
and brother-in-law side and
said, "Hey, I've lost two kids,
I know how you feel."
"And I admire that you're
taking the pain in your lives
and you're trying to do something
good for others out of it
and that's all we can do."
In moments like that,
you could hardly ask for a better leader
when you're connecting with
people in tough circumstances.
And there's a lot of tough
things going on in our country
and in the world right now and--
There are.
I think Joe Biden is sort
of a man for this moment.
Again and of course, you
know, describing that,
I'm sure it was a very emotional time
to be with those people and connecting
through such emotional times
and such difficult times.
And I know that you talking about COVID,
have had your own experience
of connecting with people,
because I believe that
you've been suffering from long COVID.
Yeah, I wouldn't use the word suffering,
I would use the word experiencing,
I got COVID, Emma, right at
the beginning in March of 2020,
when we were here passing the CARES Act
the first big COVID relief bill and
we still didn't understand
COVID that well,
and I had very non-standard symptoms,
but then as soon as I went
home, I gave COVID to my wife.
Just one more thing to feel guilty about.
And her symptoms were really normal,
"So, oh, wow this is what we have."
We had mild cases, both
of us, by mid April, 2020,
we were essentially,
you know, back to work
and doing everything we do.
But I had this one weird thing,
as soon as I got COVID just like this,
every nerve ending in my
body just started to kinda
tingle or buzz 24/7, 365.
I describe it as like,
"Every nerve ending has
had five cups of coffee."
And it's not painful and I
can work and I can exercise
and I can sleep.
I recognize that you don't
wanna say you are suffering
in light of those who are having
far more serious symptoms.
But that is still a striking thing
that your body doesn't feel
the same as it used to.
Yes.
And,
you know, it must be
frustrating, I imagine at times,
just to feel different in yourself.
Yeah it is, it's just, it's
frustrating I will say that.
I, you know, a neurologist told me,
I mean, for folks who
might be experiencing this.
That a neurological after-effect
of a virus is not uncommon.
It's not the most common thing,
but it's also not uncommon.
And not just COVID other viruses
can have a neurological after-effect.
And my neurologist said, "You
know, look, the good news is
the neurological after effects
usually don't get worse.
The bad news is they may not get better."
And it has just been sort of
constant now for two years.
It's not even a new normal because I just,
if it was a new normal,
I wouldn't notice it,
but I notice it all the time.
But again, it just connects me
with people who were dealing with it and
I started to talk about
it in committee hearings,
because I wanted folks watching to know,
there was at least somebody
on the dais who believed them, many
long COVID sufferers
are not being believed.
Yes, but just 'cause
you mentioned work there
and also COVID and the time
of reflection people have had,
I was looking back at your career
and thinking about what you
have or haven't done or nearly done.
And you've nearly been
vice president twice
I understand.
Nearly to President Obama,
losing out to a certain Joe Biden
and then nearly of course,
with Hillary Clinton,
winning the popular vote.
But still just not getting there.
How have you come to
peace with that Senator?
I call myself an electoral
college drop out.
You know,
if you're in this line of work,
there's wins and losses.
Before I was in politics,
I had a very high stakes
legal practice trying cases.
I won the biggest civil
rights jury verdict
in the history of the United States.
I also walked somebody into
the death chamber in Virginia
and held his hand while
they strapped them down
to execute him.
You have wins and losses.
And you know, life just produces that,
as soon as you think things
are going well, watch out
and on your darkest day,
a window will open.
And that's, you know, I'm 64,
I'm a lot wiser than I was
when I was half my age.
But I just feel like a life fully lived
is going to be ups and downs.
And you know, you're right,
I was nearly vice president twice,
and what that tells me is,
I'm not supposed to be vice president
and so,
and I love being a Senator.
I love being a Senator.
It was tough to be on a
ticket in 2016 and lose.
I was so thrilled.
I helped President Obama become
the first African American
President of the United States.
I threw everything into
helping Hillary Clinton
become the first woman
President of the United States.
To win the popular vote
by a significant margin
and yet fall short.
Yeah, it was tough, but
I just came back to work.
The next day the Senate was open and
just started working hard and
that's what I've been doing
since 2016.
Really?
You just went back in the next time.
I'll tell you an interesting story.
We conceded in a speech Wednesday,
the day after the election, the
Senate was closed that week.
The Senate reopened on Monday.
Came back to work early Monday morning.
First colleague who came him
to see me on that first Monday
after the election in
2016 was John McCain.
I'm in the office that
John McCain used to have.
He moved around the corner
to take John Kerry's office
when John Kerry became Secretary of State.
Get a knock at the door that
morning and it's John McCain.
He said, "I want to come
see you, I gotta tell you."
"You and I are the only
people in the Senate
who have gone through what
you've just gone through.
We are the only two now that
have been on a national ticket
and lost.
And I was running for president,
so it's even more painful than
what you're going through.
And I'll tell you, I've
got the solution for you."
And I said, "I'm all ears."
He said, "Just go right back to work."
I said, "You found me here.
First thing, first day we're open,
you found me here, didn't you?"
And then John used to say to me,
he was my chairman in Armed Services.
About every three or
four months, he'd say,
"Are you doing what I told you?
Are you doing what I told you?"
And so he kind of, you know,
was giving me a pep talk.
But that really is the
answer 'cause every day,
every day my staff and I,
we have the opportunity to
lighten somebody's burden,
help a veterans, get a, get,
you know, of veterans benefit.
Help stop somebody from
getting their home foreclosed.
I got a great bill passed in
the Foreign Relations Committee
yesterday, sort of a historic one.
If we can get it finally
done to say that no president
of the United States
can withdraw from NATO
without congressional approval.
So every day we've got a
chance to do something good,
and most days we do.
And you know that helps you
get over the sting of a loss.
I mean, I thought he was gonna say,
"I've got the answer
for you, here's a beer
and here's a whiskey chaser."
I mean...
Well, we did that too,
but that was not the,
that would've been win or lose.
He was, this was the
advice for, if you've lost.
It's been fascinating
to talk to you, Senator.
Thank you very much for your time.
I'm really glad we could do this.
Thank you.
And thank you for being
with us so much then.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.